les représentants du patronat et des
syndicats ont été reçus ce matin par
Elisabeth borne à Matignon une première
un depuis la loi sur la réforme des
retraites la réunion d'aujourd'hui
marque l'échec consternant des 100 jours
annoncés par le Président de la
République les communicants de l'Élysée
voulait nous vendre aujourd'hui un pacte
nous avons refusé ce festival de langue
de bois et exiger des actes concrets
plus de trois jours après la disparition
des milles l'enquête de terrain n'a rien
donné accident homicide enlèvement
toutes les hypothèses restent étudiées
par le parquet
il y a des brindilles il y a des
brindilles mimi t'es pas loin t'es pas
loin Mimi il est là il est là il est là
aucun indice reconnaît le procureur de
la République la commune est aujourd'hui
vide et bouclés les enquêteurs vont
maintenant analyser les données
récoltées et puis une cellule d'enquête
nationale a été sollicitée chez les
gendarmes il y a une doctrine qui dit
que on essaye au maximum de suivre ces
pistes même si ça s'avère être souvent
une perte de temps pour la simple et
bonne raison que parfois il s'agit
d'aveu déguisé sous l'excuse du
paranormal un Vieux-Condé dans le Nord
l'homme de 72 ans agressé devant chez
lui la semaine dernière a succombé à ses
blessures il était sorti demandé à des
jeunes de faire moins de bruit lorsqu'il
a été roué de coup par trois d'entre eux
les trois mises en examen ne présentent
aucun antécédent judiciaire les mineurs
de 14 ans et 17 ans sont scolarisés et
le jeune homme de 18 ans aurait quant à
lui interrompu sa scolarité en classe de
première
l'ensemble des intéressés semble avoir
manifesté en état des regrets il y a
Éric Zemmour qui lui il voit un
franco-syné il Zemmour pour conquête
Philippe et victime d'un Franck aussi de
est-ce que vous êtes en train de dire
que la société française est raciste il
y a toujours eu du racisme oui la
société française est raciste mais il y
a toujours eu du racisme
on l'est tous un petit peu on a tous un
rapport à la différence à l'altérité il
Zemmour ce qui veut dire si je décrypte
c'est que c'est probablement des enfants
si je suis sa rhétorique habituels qui
sont la deuxième troisième génération
des migration sauf qu'a priori c'est pas
le cas au-delà de la douleur qu'on
ressent tous pour lui ses proches sa
famille ça atteste aussi de cette ultra
violence de cette violence décomplexée
contre laquelle nous devons lutter avec
détermination et nous le faisons ce qui
serait nécessaire dans une situation de
crise majeure pour le pays de crise de
l'autorité on l'a vu de crise à l'école
une école qui s'effondre et c'est aussi
une des causes de ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière alors que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui est
nulissime c'était de la mise en place
d'un dispositif exceptionnel puisqu'il
s'appuiera pour les 13 et 14 juillet sur
130 000 policiers et gendarmes agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc 45000
chaque soir spécialement équipé et
organisé pour procéder à la lutte contre
les violences urbaines selon les mêmes
modes Modus opéranzy que pendant les
quatre jours d'émeutes c'est-à-dire que
nous mobiliserons le raid le GIGN la
Berry et ce terrible ça se dira à quel
point de qu'elle défondrement on en est
arrivé sur ces questions essentielles
d'autorité de de l'État sur qu'on a peur
de ne pas être capable de maintenir
l'ordre sur des événements festifs c'est
c'est vraiment la communauté nationale
qui est qui est qui est atteinte un jour
qui aurait un jour de liesse communauté
nationale risque de ne pas l'être et on
a on a raison d'avoir des inquiétudes
dispositifs conçus pour dissuader
disperser interpeller avec une
mobilisation forte évidemment des
effectifs petit événement
tant est en floraison pour la première
fois depuis son arrivée au jardin
botanique en 2018 un phénomène qui a ses
désagréments puisqu'il dégage une odeur
de viande avariée et oui j'ai pas
coutume de repousser des choses qui ne
sont pas programmées
je crois avoir fait deux fois des
interviews du 14 juillet donc vous me
m’accorderez à voir une certaine liberté
avec cette pratique vous aviez évoqué le
14 juillet oui j'ai dit que je ferai un
point autour du 14 juillet je vous
rassure je ferai un point autour du 14
juillet